[Music]
one of the important themes that we see
arising in ursula k le guin's second
earth sea novel the tombs of ottawan
is that of making choices choices that
are determinative
of
who one is what we could call
fateful choices those which place you on
this trajectory or a different one and
the character who is most involved in
doing these things in an explicit way
is the young woman arha who
recovers her name tanar
and the question is who is she going to
be what is she going to do now the first
one arises while they are still
in the labyrinth after they've gotten to
a sort of crisis she and ged have been
talking for a while she's come into
conflict with the other high priestess
castle and thinks that causal may in
fact try to do her in in one way or
another
and she says
i don't know what to do i'm afraid i'm
afraid of the dark and get answers her
you must make a choice either you must
so there's two different possibilities
here you must leave me
lock the door go up to your altars and
give me to your masters then go to the
priestess castle and make your peace
with her and that is the end of the
story
or
you must unlock the door and go out of
it with me leave the tombs leave otto on
come with me overseas and that is the
beginning of the story you must be arja
or you must be tenar you cannot be both
and this has the classic framework of a
dilemma right we have two horns the die
and the dilemma means two you got you
can do a or you can do b
you can't do both and
yeah i mean you could just do nothing
whatsoever but then you know
she's going to die uh because of castle
so these are the the live options you
could say and we'll come back to this in
just a moment
a little bit after this in the beginning
of chapter
10 after sh after the ring of uh
aerith akba has been fixed and it's put
on her arm she actually says
here we go he says i wish i had my staff
and she says it's just outside the door
i brought it why did you bring it he
asked curiously
i thought of and now we see a third
option taking you to the door
and letting you go
and get says that was a choice you
didn't have you could keep me a slave
and be a slave or set me free and come
free with me come little one take
courage
turn the key
so
she had a different third option in mind
and get is saying that's not really an
option now notice how he's reinforced
this we have give ged to the the unnamed
ones make him a sacrifice essentially
restore her old life the story ends
she remains a slave to the unnamed ones
her masters
and to a way of life that she you know
it now sees as as deeply problematic or
she can escape with ged not just from
the tombs
but from
ottawa from the entire kargash isles and
go overseas with him into what she knows
as the inner lands what we know as the
archipelago
of earthsea
and one of these involves freedom one of
these involves servitude one of these
means
going back to being arha the other one
means
becoming
tenor it's he says be tenar but it's
really
a matter of becoming because she doesn't
really know who 10r is does she
so
she chooses to go with ged to embrace a
future a story that is just starting now
and then a little bit later
in chapter 12 the very beginning of the
chapter
she has to make another choice
here
she feels that ged has betrayed her has
tricked her has
made use of her
uh here we go uh she says where was he
now on what way of the spirit did he
walk she could never follow him
he had made her follow him he had called
her by her name and she had come
crouching to his hand as a little wild
desert rabbit had come to him out of the
dark now that he had the ring now the
tombs were in ruin and their priest is
foresworn forever
now he didn't need her
and went away where she could not follow
he would not stay with her he had fooled
her and would leave her desolate so what
we see her saying here essentially to
herself is that
she didn't really make a choice he
tricked her he got her to come along
with these promises he in fact seduced
her not sexually but we could say
existentially
and
she she now feels a sense of resentment
about that and she has a dagger this
dagger is one of the things that was
given to her as we we learned
she did dances with it she's never used
it for anything
and she takes the dagger and realizes
that she could kill him on the spot
as a matter of fact
she would it says she would serve her
masters still though they had betrayed
her and forsaken her they would guide
and drive her hand in the last arc act
of darkness they would accept the
sacrifice she turned upon the man her
knife held back in her right hand behind
her hip
as she did so he raised his face slowly
and looked at her
he had the look of one come from a long
way off one who has seen terrible things
his face was calm but full of pain as he
gazed up to her and seemed to see her
more and more clearly his expression
cleared at last he said tenar as if in
greeting and reached up his hand to
touch the band of pierced and carve and
silver on his wrist time we were going
at the sound of his voice the fury left
her she was afraid and
what's going on here so she is also
making a choice but it's a choice that
you could say there are conditions
within
him
not trying to defend himself but merely
reaching out to her in trust and
touching the symbol of their their trust
the ring of ereth akbar
helps to bring her out of this state and
as we see he says or he says you'll
leave them behind tenner you're going
free now so
she was wavering once again between
sacrificing ged
to the masters who have also betrayed
her but this would restore some some
meaning some unity some some
sense of familiarity to her life right
or
do something more scary trust ged
who she thinks may betray her who
already perhaps has betrayed her
and leave the masters behind and go off
into an unseen future immediately after
that they get the boat on rollers and
take it down to
the ocean to sail away
as they're on the waters the third
choice arises the third fateful choice
now
tenar
is
becoming much more aware of the evil
that she herself has done becoming aware
of it not just as things that happened
or choices that had to be made in the
spur of the moment or things that you
know she did but it was really the will
of the masters the nameless ones the old
powers of the earth she has become aware
of her own
participation
in evil and she tells this is after they
they bring the story to a close about
the the ring and the two children who
became old people on the island and she
says
i would ask you something ask i do not
wish to go to the inner lands to have
nor i do not belong there in the great
cities among foreign men i do not belong
to any land i betrayed my own people i
have no people and i have done a very
evil thing
put me alone on an island as the king's
children were left on a lone isle where
there are no people where there is no
one
leave me and take the ring to havnor it
is yours not mine it has nothing to do
with me
nor have your people let me be by myself
so she is making a choice but she's
articulating this choice with ged
because of course she can't get to an
island by herself
so this makes it something that they can
discuss a choice that they can work
through together and he says what evil
have you done tenar
and she says i ordered that three men be
shut into a room beneath the throne and
they starved to death they died of
hunger and thirst they died and are
buried there in the under tomb the
tombstones fell on their graves
and he asks is there more
mana
that death is on my soul ged says
because ged struck mana and he fell into
the pit
and she says no
he died because he loved me and was
faithful he thought he was protecting me
he held the sword above my neck when i
was little he was kind to me when i
cried
i was never kind to him i will not go to
havnor i will not go with you find some
iowa no one comes and put me there and
leave me the evil must be paid for
i am not
free she is not free of the evil but she
is free to atone for the evil that she
has done so there is a choice to be made
here
ged helps her to remake this choice
how by explaining to her
the situation a new interpretation of it
which can be chosen he she he says to
her listen tanar heed me you were the
vessel of evil the evil is poured out it
is done it is buried in its own tomb you
were never made for cruelty and darkness
you were made to hold light as a lamp
burning holds and gives its light i
found the lamp on lit i won't leave it
on some desert island like a thing found
and cast away i'll take you to hovnor
and say to the princes of earth see look
in the place of darkness i found the
light her spirit by her an old evil was
brought to nothing by her i was brought
out of the grave by her the broken was
made whole and where there was hatred
there will be peace
and tanara said i will not in agony i
cannot it is not true so what we see
here is
ged is is
he's not just preferring an
interpretation he's saying listen this
is the way it's got to be and she is
she's rejecting it she's pushing it away
he adds something else to it which helps
to change her mind
he says
after that i'll take you away from the
princes and the rich lords
it's true you have no place there you
are too young and two wise
i'll take you
to my own land to gaunt where i was born
to my old master ogian he's an old man
now a very great mage a man of quiet
heart he lives in a small house on the
great cliffs of ray albee high over the
seas i lived there once with him when i
was younger than you are now i didn't
stay long i hadn't the sense to stay i
went off seeking evil and sure enough i
found it but you come escaping evil
seeking freedom seeking silence for a
while until you find your own way
there you will find kindness and silence
tanar there the lamp will burn out of
the wind awhile will you do that
and she says i will
oh i wish it were sooner that we could
go there now
so
get is is changing the terms you you
have to go to havnor because we have to
bring the ring and this is for you know
all the people of earth see but you
don't have to stay
you don't have to be a princess
go on from a priestess to a princess in
a land where you don't know anybody i
will take you to my own homeland where i
have a great friend who will shelter you
and teach you and help you on the way
even though i won't be there
with you because i have to go and do
other wizardly things
you'll still be there and he reminds her
as well all you have to do is call upon
me and i will come so he he's telling
her she's not been abandoned that
enables her
to make once again
the choice for life
not for death
not for
atonement not for
evil not for retribution but for an open
future that is as yet undetermined
but one in which she can step one in
which she can
grow and this prepares the way
for the other books yet to come
particularly
the
fourth
and the sixth book in which tenar is
going to be
an incredibly important
central character
you